there are graffiti that are so poorly written
and decisional people put them as they
also do not understand
that people say what they want but that
they say it well
a misspelling is a lack of
respect
[Music]
we are spelling action I remove we
dedicate ourselves to correcting the mistake  of
spelling and grammar in the traffic
of the streets of our city
we improve the world one punctuation mark
at a time
what motivated us to start all this
was this graffiti that was so badly
written that it was basically like a
moral imperative
this is a  hardware store and buy a
red spray can and correct the mistakes
of that graffiti because it was
unbelievable
and it is something that we should not tolerate
in the type of interventions that
we do vandalism was already
perpetrated before us
[Music]
we simply arrived  to correct
what is already wrong in that graffiti
we started with a wall and that
wall led us to start correcting the
mistakes of  spelling in the neighborhood that
led us to start correcting
misspellings in this city
hopefully soon in this country
and in the world
and if we are going to attract a
lot of time here
need is full of romantics
then there is a lot of
romantic graffiti in the city a lot
messages of love and of course if they are poorly
written those messages reach us as they
should reach those who should, a
league of rigor to the heart
then the movement began in Quito
about two years ago now and
from that other groups have also been created
in cities like  madrid in
guayaquil also
sudan writing from monterrey from mexico from
rosario from buenos aires- from many
cities in latin america from spain
many people in fact write to us
asking how they can do to
start the movement in their respective
cities
and as we said it is just a
matter of going  to buy red spray
make a stencil and basically
start intervening ourselves  Our aim is to
make the city more pleasant, called
diverse, more interesting, more cosmopolitan,
we will not give up until we live
in a world free of vandalism, art,
thank you
[Music]